now we're going to turn to someone who's
been following what's driving voters to
the polls CBS News elections and surveys
director Anthony salvanto is with us to
talk about what to expect from election
day I want to ask you about election day
and uh Tony but Anthony sorry I got my
Anthony's and Tony's mixed up but we've
already had people voting what do we
know about those who voted and is it uh
the vote we would have expected on
Election Day or are a whole bunch of
people voting and that might mean
election day we'll add to maybe record
turnout yeah this is we're looking at
the advance vote here and I expect
that's going to be about half of all
votes cast so we've hit about 40 million
might go up as many as 60 million when
all is said and done before we get to
tomorrow morning and then we're
expecting right now near record turnout
could hit around 120 million the thing
about the advance vote John is Democrats
use the advance vote they use mail
voting and they try to build up a lead
with that when I look at the advance
vote Yes in a lot of places Democrats
seem to have a slight lead but is it big
enough off is the question and I think
that electorate looks a little bit older
than perhaps Democrats would like and I
think if they need to get that youth
vote out there they're going to be
playing catch-up a little bit come
Tuesday we keep hearing long night late
night everybody's ready get your get
your Wheaties get whatever sleep
medication you need to to stay awake but
so when you're looking at the as we as
the night begins what are you looking
for in terms of geography that tells you
anything as a votes come as a vote
tallies come in yes this will be filled
with a lot of coffee
the geography starts with Georgia in my
mind because they close at seven they
close at seven o'clock so we're going to
start to get an indicator from the exit
polls the national exit polls the
Georgia exit polls about what turnout
looks like and also about whether the
Democrats can start to play that
catch-up that I described or if it looks
like very Republican because Republicans
are going to turn out and force they
tell us tomorrow so then we get to
Georgia we do North Carolina we get to
Ohio and then it's then it's off into
the night from there but that's your
first indicator out of the exit poles
and then how it breaks if it's strongly
Republican what about demographically
like what demos are you looking at why
is that important yeah first thing I'm
looking at is young people because as
we've reported Democrats need a lot of
young people to turn out of course right
and then the other thing we're looking
at and I think this is this is going to
be really key is what's the split
between that early and advance and uh
and election day vote right and I urge
everybody to have patience because they
might count the ballots in separate
buckets and they might count the
election day when Republicans might do
better and then they might count the
advance vote a little bit later and we
have to wait for those votes to come in
and so going slow doesn't mean it's
wrong or doesn't mean there's any
problems it's just patience it's
exciting yeah but we also have to have
patience to let it all unfold as those
accounts I think we have to keep
reminding people that too don't expect
to have numbers that that right that
night yeah keep reminding people fill up
your cup with some coffee oh you got it
long next couple of days we appreciate
you CBS News will bring you full
coverage of the results of tomorrow's
midterm elections beginning at 8 pm
Eastern right here on CBS